foreign
and welcome back to another video by
simply learn this is anubhub and in this
video we will be creating a vue.js
project
but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our Channel already make
sure to hit the Subscribe button and
press the Bell icon so you will never
miss any update from Simply learn so
without further Ado let's see how our
application will look like at the end of
this video
so I'll open this chrome where I have
already created this quiz project
this is how our project will look like
at the end of this tutorial
this will give us a hover
effect whenever we click on
it will light up as a green
like this and if we click on the wrong
option it will click as red
at the end
it'll give us a score we can add as much
as questions as we want
so
let's just
go to our coding part
before that let's first see a little
history of UTS and what is vue.js former
Google employee when you is the creator
of ugs view JS initial version was
released in February 2014 and is
currently rated as 64
828 stars on GitHub making it highly
well liked so what is vue.js
this is what a history of UJS was so now
what is ugs a JavaScript framework
called ugs is used to create user
interface it provides a declarative and
component based programming approach
that enables you to quickly create user
interface no matter how straightforward
or complex that may be it works on top
of Industry standards HTML CSS and
JavaScript
when using bluejs you can add directives
which are HTML attributes to HTML HTML
apps can functions thanks to vue.js
directives
built-in and user defined directives are
available in ugs you don't need prior
knowledge of webpack we will npm or
anything else to start with View
but view makes it simple for you to rely
on them when you are ready
now
let's just move on to our coding part
for that we need to First create a
folder
so on our desktop I'm going to create a
folder
quiz
pack
let's just save it here
and inside our Visual Studio code
will open this folder
this is an empty folder
now let's start the development process
for this quiz project
for that I'll open the terminal but then
I'll press Ctrl face button
by just pressing ctrlvis backlink this
terminal can be opened you can also open
the terminal from here by just clicking
on Terminal and then the new terminal
this will also open this
here
let's create a project for that I'll
write command in VM create
like
that's right
so those who don't know about the white
white is a powerful engine
that we'll discuss later
you'll get to know about it very soon so
let's click it
with the help of right we can install it
when you lie JavaScript view react
pre-react lit silver and other Fringe
works as well so in this project we are
using view so we'll go to the view and
then let's check we don't need
typescript for that customize with view
project
so we'll just click on JavaScript
so it's showing first you have to go to
the current directory which is current
directory White Project this is the
folder that this has been created
so in this source file
we don't need these two so let's suppose
delete this projects
I'll delete this folder component
because it's a big enough to take so
most of the code will be in this
app.view
only
let's just delete this also
but first let's run this
CD white object
now we have come inside this project
after that we will install Run npm Run f
Lex let's run this
foreign
right now the issue
okay I forgot to tell you about the
extension that we gonna use
I have installed this extension
you also have to install this let's cut
it so you can see it
so you are have to install this
extension by just clicking on this card
extension and then here you will type
new language features voila and in that
we have to install this
let's move on to our code
now first let's install
let's first install sure
because we need npm job
programs
so after installing mpm let's now run
this website
now
as you can see it's running fine let's
see
so you can now
just click it's showing Control Plus
click Ctrl and then click
delete it some components from here
these two projects that goes here so
that's why this error is coming
so
this is a code
console open this approach View
deleted and then let's start working on
the function of this program
let's just leave this part also this CSS
file because all the CSS I'm inside this
so vue.js is referred as a progressive
framework as you all know because
changes and improvements are made on a
regular basis because it makes it easier
for us to construct single page
application and dynamic user interfaces
so in this application I'm going to make
it as a single page application
for that stay tuned I'm gonna start the
development process
so for this I'll write
sit down
it just gives me space here inside this
let's now create a temperature
let's create a guide
here
let's first
add some styling
so this star is for
because we want to add this
the meaning of this star is globally
because we want to add this part
globally
so let's give it a margin
0
and then
after that the Box sizing
box
after that okay on family
it's good
because that's important
okay
come on
great
[Music]
you kidding
yes
let's create the body time
foreign
than all the properties
list
or D
inside this body time I'll write the
background color
s
six
let's give it a legend
let's
just save it
it's not working
foreign
foreign
Control Plus click so this link will be
open inside the Chrome so as you can see
it showing the blue background at
we have written here it's been solder as
of now
let's
list
C now
we'll just give it a
okay
now let me just move up and let's see
okay so we can find the mark
let's see inside the H1 done
Android
hello
let's just save this again okay let's
see welcome to Simply learn
so
as you can see it's working fine let's
just delete this part
and something else inside this so let's
work on the script
part first then we can
move ahead
so let's first import the important
modules now
so let's
swing from view this is
the refresh module is from
View
so let's add one more
okay
there's also a few module
now
it's just call this first
it's not fetching it
so let's now create
so let's try to go
and he said this let's create a function
but let's first give it
of course the question is
first we need to add the three parts
question and then we have to declare the
answer and then we'll do get the options
as well then the option that has been
selected we're gonna add that later
let's add for this tuition here
and I had as many questions as you want
and you can add
position like so this is a very
interesting project that
students create on their degrees
stay clear the question
like this let's try to
question or what
is
cheers
let's skip until later after we
doing so
edit options
so we're gonna hit options like this
to
this reactor free work
a framework
so let's give it another option
at another option
and
that will be
so
let's give
it okay it's good
and then
yes okay
so what is vfgs you have all you want to
get someone's Edition
you will have to give the answer for
this part so we have to give the answer
first here
so the answer of this question is
Library so I'm gonna add the answer so
this
to add the option here so
it all works as a star 0 1 2.
so the zero one is this framework one is
this library and the
two is this language so the answer for
this is one so we'll write 1 and then
let's just save it you have to do the
scripting or not to make it look like
that I have shown you well here
so let's just give it a
option of selected and the user has
selected option
so let's
okay sensitive
user has not been easily not
yeah
after that
chocolates
just copy this
control copy
one and two
the last part we don't need let's just
change this question
that second question would be
let's give
what is the full form of HTML yeah that
would be a nice question
you all must know this
foreign
I
go
language
what is it
when you go down to this
let's repeat options only
let's add marker
foreign
language
so we need to declare the answer here
so we're gonna declare 0 1
okay let's just save it
this selected option would be null only
let's move on to the final equation for
this
it's just
give this as
as you're working on view let's
oh one question of you let's see if you
delete this and the answer would be same
only framework like with your language
so view is a you have to tell me there's
a framework Library language
so view is a framework
let's just now save this part
and everything
fine
let's just see as it
okay no it's not showing anything
just move ahead and let's create the
functionality so
and then the quiz completed option
that we are going to give
let's just add quiz
and we can't
he did
let's give it the reference first
it will not show
it's another piece it
after that really create another point
in The Cutting question
the question is that question is showing
again it will give it their reference
commission with the portion which will
start from zero
get
now we are also
which I have shown you inside that the
score of 3 home score how much score do
you have
better questions that you have given
so we'll write this
function also
you did
give it a function
just let's just do this
create a function here so we'll write
lead
s
[Music]
after that from the
action that we had having then the value
of that and then we'll use the mappings
here
I'll explain it inside
the function
after that
will give it a value for its
if
p is equals to question
color
if the beta is
giving selecting the
answer
equals to equals to
keep
answer
then you will give the value of
plus plus
so this is what whenever we click on the
right answer it will move ahead
otherwise it will give us a output of
wrong
so let's just complete this
let's just turn the value in
value
reference
oh okay with you
or get conclusion
so like
between them
all right
questions
that
is
that's conclusion so let's
see
okay
in that third function
foreign
[Music]
questions
foreign
X
equals to call it first
started
so let's just now finish this by just
returning it
the
question
okay
let's just return this question
okay
I'll be Pursuit
let's open my phone you just need to
call it
so what
let's just see everything's working
finally not
okay
so the problem is that's why it's not
fetching so let's just
because we have returned after that so
we can return it as let's give
let
cool
now we're talking perfect
let's move ahead
and we have done with the question spot
and now we'll conduct and survive
the answer we'll take a question part
only
let's just twist on the question it's
done after that
let's get
this e to find us equals function
after that we will give
questions dot value guess
the current
question not value
and then the answer we just selected so
we'll write this selected
value the target
and then the you will get fetched
so after that
subscribe
let's now give it a value Target
it's good you know
let's create a multi-function
and then we'll click on the next
question so we are going to write
function for the next question
okay
against
yeah
right
let's give it
if
possible question
is less than
questions
okay
touching them
10 minus one
will give
True Value Plus Plus
now let's just return this
this
last one let's
further
we have created one for cat current
version set answer and the next question
it's just
completed
and then at the end we'll show the value
like a score
so it's done so
the functionalities we have completed
here only
now let's work on the UI part
what the user will see so that all will
come under memory part
so inside the template we will give
us
now inside this
let's get a name Plus
and save this
mean up
okay
inside this mean now I'm going to write
once it's one time
save this H1 we will write the heading
that will come and so I will write the
quiz
okay fine you can edit it or however you
want
but I think like this it's not
so after that we'll give it this section
okay
after that let's just save this
showing now it's not showing that's okay
anyways we haven't gave it some selling
or not so don't show us anything
let's give it a section
after this
let's create a plus
so inside this let's clear this and plus
name as
distortion
listening
it's now a little more red
it's just
create the get function call a little
bit function here
there it is let's write the equivalent
question
because
foreign
score
now we'll display the score so that
we're gonna write
score and then this
click inside this didn't get the
question name so whenever we click on
the right question it will get the score
the questions dot length and I will
click on the Red version
will give us 1.2 so yeah
save it
after that we let's first see the
application let's
this
you think it's showing the question
similar and the question is and the
score is this
okay we have added three questions so
it's showing us the three score
but it's not showing us the options
we're gonna add the option part also
so let's just after this
let's work on this option part
let's create a class of options
these are these options we're gonna
label it
as
label
to this as for
okay let's just just create it simply to
give you an idea then we'll do
an input tape
button or we can use
oh
let's just name it as
Nixon
so let's
me
hit
current
okay
foreign
so let's save it rest inside this
yeah
so now just give it a little bit of B
for
inside this will pass through
option and the index part
option and then index
so now it's um
yeah
and said that it is really good the
common question about options
it's not gonna get there later
we will press on the key
it will be index
okay
let's
face it
okay fine it's showing right
let's just save it
and it's true and buttons we're going to
chain this and we'll work on The Styling
part
so now we will on this only
so okay fine it's so funny
it's just
you have a glass
thank you
insert the option
early brackets and then say this
okay let's make this and set a new line
so we can play it clearly
after that let's just wait
ing
it's just
have an option
the selected
in order to click on the right question
because
index
now let's move forward
and set this index part
we are going to write it's just a little
different now let's read the code
it's the index that will be equals to
the current equation and then to fetch
the answer we'll write this after that
if we're going to click on the right
question
according to this are correct otherwise
and then nothing
just okay
let's save it and after that I know it's
looking
okay
so I have to put my dick
let's just move forward
okay let's create another class
okay okay inside this it's fine
inside this
we're going to create another
okay
and this
is function right
yeah you know it's looking
okay let's
like this the selected option
Revenue
have used here as sanity operators
here next
time
this
okay
selected
oops
actually let's see this okay if I'm
flipping
it's just not the output
so
let's see
enough let's just disable this buttons
so whenever we click on this other
button if we will hit this button
of that we need to
give this one the answer
just
trying to move it says
and then if we don't
need to answer
so it's all right let's save this
you're fine
no will you can go to the new model
investment grade
you get current questions selected so
whenever we select an option we want
that B shown
a little bit so if you can save the
different name
this one
who
and then
so whenever this is what whenever we
click on any any question
of being disabled
so it's all right
okay fine let's just read this once more
so everything is fine
let's see yeah
inside this okay no yeah everything is
looking fine now
click button part you will click
any button
is
set on
we have also declared the set answer
okay
let's just
let's just go back to uh
okay as you can see this is what we have
created and I will click on this button
other buttons were disabled
so
now
let me go back to our code
now we'll fetch the options also
so by just going here
now we have given the click on this
let's write it
see
change
after that let's create
this and
we'll see the answers that we have
created
so it's the option
save it for more cleanliness
so as you can see all the options
already app is showing so whenever you
click on the react framework the library
and the language got disabled we cannot
click on this once
okay
let's go back to code
now we have gone to the last part of
this and it's enacted that we'll create
okay let's go more space
let's create a button inside this button
I'm gonna write
when they will click on the next
question
if you will
disabled
folder
yet
it's
like this let's create
and I will get in the current question
index
e minus one so I will go to the next
question the length of the equations
with minus one and this means whenever
we if we have three questions it will
just cut the one part and then the two
will be left it will show like two
questions will be left
so when it will be finished
it will show us the score so for that
let's read
finish
and then we'll get
in the kit
and question
dot selected
not
select an option
okay let's read
it as soon as
to that
Android
do it a little
okay fine
so we can write
a
question
this next question let's just save it
and see
okay perfect
whenever we click on this let me just
click on the next question so it isn't
looking cool
yeah let's go back to our code
and then let's see here
now we will work on the finish last
screen part
so inside
build this section we will create
another section
oops
is
they have created and else
so we have created this if if you will
the answer will be there otherwise
it will give us whenever the versions
will end it will give us this so let's
write if else
inside this
okay
let's do
for you
let's just do it in a second
this was just about this language you
have finished
so
good
okay
let's just see what's the issue here
coming
despite let's let's see what's the issue
okay
well the first just add the paragraph
name
after they've stood down whenever we go
to the last question it will fetch the
spot
so
great
okay using this
we'll write our score
is
the score is and then the
function per square
check so we will write
score
and then the question
because in which concussion will leave
them
in the left then only you can give us
the right
okay you have to go to add the start so
inside this template
inside this
section bar
I'll write V if
and then
I'm gonna say
repeated
whenever the course will be completed
this function will be run and if not
this function will be run
smoking
let's just save it back to our code
let's just see you have finished the
quiz and this is
the
same
um
[Music]
let's just go to the section bar at the
end the template 16 plus okay
so
can be fixed
let's just do it again and just see if
therefore but anything to add
see okay
everything's looks
okay length section
yeah
okay let's just see here
okay the first question is seeing let's
add the next
next next
and then I will click on this finish
button
it's not fetching the right option it
should show us the
this part if you have finished the so we
have to write here
let's see what's each coming here
let's find the issue here what's coming
because the first button is not working
okay let's first
if it's complete let's save it
and let's see
if you find the quiz I'm simply don't
react to the framework Library let's
just
add this system here so and see okay
fine
it's my score also this over is three
one out of three
let's just now style this part
and for styling
so I'm going to give it a like
start with the app one
which will write Dot
say this let's write display should be
reflex Direction
[Music]
two
and very tough
save it
sorry
everything's let's
do some staying here and say did that
hit
the
restaurant
and say so
foreign
after that the code is cf610
we can maintain the colors also
okay then
let's give it a worth of 100
about
human oxide would be
that's where it will be
six let's write 600 more save it and see
okay
fine it's fine good
we can do some selling of options right
and then this button also I don't know
it's freaking cool
let's move forward
after that
let's work on this
with
this let's give it a display Flex
justify contain space between
the margin
Construction
look at that
it's
said quiz
questions
let's save this
okay fine for me
yeah
color
zero nine
I would say it should be
an endpoint
you can use
1.5 and we'll we have the scoreboard
125.
on this
what
is 44
score
save this scoreboard
White
and the phone says
should be one group
two things now let's save it
and see how it's looking
yeah it's looking great
yeah we will work on this
in a minute let's hope on the options
bar now
what options
inside this let's give it a margin
bottom of
one room
save it
to that we work on the option bar
foreign
okay
if
you know I know it's given now
then give it a much
um
save it
yep
yeah you can just change the color of
this if it's not
great but that's fine
now we will make the cursive printer
which is very important
of course runs pointer
see you
sir
pointer so we will
do this it will be pointer let's work on
the option over
be covered on any options about it on
Commercial change
let's give it the color of
Orange
is the event and see if it's looking
good
it's not showing the over effect now but
we will make it happen
it's still way
okay let's just
okay the correct options first
which is not
correct
let's say this will give it the
background color
you could remove
let's do c c e
d
until the color of green to darker also
and it's fine
let's just copy this part
at least
and then
it's good
now we're going to work on this moment
[Music]
for the last update
button
s
and it's just
okay
let's just go ahead
and disabled also
option
disabled
this kind of
projectiles some individuals who work on
this and you can also
need the course eyes that is reactive
level if you want to be a slow stack
developer you can take a course you can
call our
helpline number and get the course
YouTube channel
there's so many other courses we have
created and we create very good content
on daily basis so you can also check it
out
so let's
write the input now
let's give it display
and after that let's work on the button
now
save the buttons
evidence would be done
good morning
I have the cursor
budding in one room
in it
okay
2571d
hello
foreign
foreign
through this one
okay
things like this
I've got a radius 0.5
disable button
oh
but in British reported this option to
speak
shown on the screen
[Music]
and then we work on this
last minute tags
and
size
two run
Martin
let's do them
okay in the text alignment should be
centered
and for the students screen let's open
the diagonal
and the color of this would be
let's
all right
please
just save it
let's see the output now
it's disabling the other parts
it's disabling the other parts
and it's
I put text next question and
the framework
so let's invest it your score is two out
of three
so I'm sure you have loved this video
so if you like this video make sure to
like and share it
thank you for watching and stay tuned
for more from Simply learn
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here